Stifler in American Pie franchise is
that something do you still get offers
for them like hey we got another idea we
got another idea do they still throw
that at you or is that kind of doesn't
it you're not interested in that anymore
you know what
um no I think
I love that character I I
for a while though I was like especially
after the last one we filmed in like
2011 or 12 and I was like okay this is a
great bookend to this character you know
um I didn't think I didn't think it'd be
fun to play the character again and then
as time went on I was like and as the
world has changed and I thought that
seeing that character today
um could be really interesting and we've
started I saw Jason Biggs not long ago
we shot a commercial
um and this is like a couple weeks ago
and we were just kind of talking about
some ideas because we thought it would
have to be it would have to be a perfect
idea it would have to you know because
obviously so much has changed comedies
have changed and but
I think I think the thing about that
character too is that when it comes to
comedies like that character allowed me
to do so much
you know you could be he could like say
so many things that were inappropriate
but yet he still kind of loved him and
there was like physical comedy and all
sorts of stuff that I don't really get a
chance to do with other characters so
even just selfishly you know I think
that would be fun but I don't know I
don't I don't know if they'll ever
because
yeah I think comedies have changed so
much that that movie would have to
change and adapt and you know be more
relatable
um so we'll see maybe Stifler has an
identity or gender identity crisis and
he's like I think I think so and then
your son's like are you out of your
freaking mind you're a man what
are you talking about yeah that's the
movie you just you just cracked the code
come on